Washington's denying China's statements
that a U.S to store has been forced from
the South China Sea on Thursday the
Chinese military said it drove the
vessel away from disputed Waters near
the Paracel Islands by the U.S Navy says
its destroyers continuing its routine
operations in the area and has not been
expelled coutinhoes joining us now live
from Beijing what's the background to
this Katrina
well it's certainly not the first time
that Washington and Beijing have
disagreed over what's happening in the
South China Sea but what makes this
potentially dangerous is that this is
happening at a time when Beijing and
Washington are having very tense
relationships and distrust between both
sides are at an all-time high now
according to China they followed the U.S
guided missile destroyer the Milius they
said that it crossed without permission
illegally into this area that Beijing
calls shisha by the Paracel Islands it
says that China's Navy monitored the
ship and then ultimately drove it away
and Beijing says by by this action the
U.S is creating instability in the
region now Washington has released a
counter claim saying that this is a
false statement in that the Milius
continues what it says our freedom of
navigation operations in international
waters now China claims much of the
South China Sea despite that
resource-rich region being claimed by
also many of its neighbors this area
where this confrontation took place is a
seven kilometer Square zoren by the
parasol Islands which is also claimed by
Taiwan and uh by the uh by Vietnam now
the U.S says that China has been
increasing its activities here bullying
other countries and certainly it has
been building up artificial Islands here
intensifying its military activities and
as a result we've seen the U.S focus on
the indo-pacific for for in more areas
it's done deals with Manila for example
example to build some bases in the
Philippines it's also agreed to supply
Australia with nuclear-powered
submarines now Beijing says that all of
this amounts to encroachment on its
territory Xi Jinping says that this is
encirclement and baining is simply
responding by protecting its own
sovereignty Katrina thank you very much
Katrina you talking to us from Beijing